when I was in fifth grade I won an
eating contest by eating five
chicken-fried steaks I used to volunteer
at the Palo Alto VA hospital to help
them perform autopsies when I lived in
Australia I used to work nights as a
bartender as a professional mover as
well
I drove bakery school to come to
Stanford one of us is lying and we hope
by the end of our presentation you have
a better idea of who that was today
we're going to make you into the best
two truths and a lie players the GSB has
ever seen because today we're here to
talk to you about the body language of
deception we're going to be drawing
heavily on research by body language
expert Carol Gomez and with this
knowledge you should be able to spot
liars in games in interviews in
negotiations and even presentations we
communicate a lot with our bodies we
learned earlier in the quarter that over
half of the total impact of a message is
communicated non-verbally the same is
true with line so non verbals can be
important and reliable tells and our
presentation today we're going to start
from the top and work down
detailing common cues of deception we're
going to start with the face move to the
hands and end with the feet have you
ever thought of our in sunglasses for
business meeting five tough negotiation
for a date probably not
that will sound weird however so however
some people do it
poker players do it why did they do it
because I didn't go to Stanford now they
do it because they know that your eyes
talk more than you want them to do once
one thing the pupils the pupils are
different and directly wired to your
brain and because a director right your
brain does not much you can do about it
when you're excited they're going to
dilate if you dis simulator
interested they're going to retract
Parker's player don't want you to see
their hands through their eyes that's a
way by which you can receive through
your eyes when you disable eight
typically your eyes going to start
blinking frenetically much faster than
you usually do all you're going to avoid
eye contact altogether police know these
cues very well so luckily for you in
Silicon Valley and the US generally
while you're going to work people don't
wear sunglasses even don't California
you never know another way where you can
read people's 9 through the face because
you're good mammal you know the
expression of the six major emotion
smile smiling associative happiness
sadness anger disgust but the project
has ever been no them they're universal
so people are going to try to fake it
let me give you two advice to hint how
to detect it the first one is the
emotion shows first on the face the
first thing that's going to come if your
emotion come at the same time as you
speak then such a dissimulation it's
fake so second one is an emotion
actually lasts less than a second so any
manifestation demonstration of this
emotion if it lasts more than one second
you're probably taking it as well
one last thing it's on your tongue
in a recent poll by a great newspaper
four percent of American say that they
believe that lesson people were among
the u.s. and trying to take over the US
government I cannot comment on the
veracity of that but I can give you two
things first being called lizard is not
a compliment on your honesty second is
your tongue is going to start and the
pressure to flee phonetically in that
short if John Kerry in 90 minutes 90
second testimony flips this tongue like
a snake eight times I'll let you make up
your mind about what it says but I can
tell you one thing keep your tongue in
looking at the eyes and the face is that
enough though you also want to pay
attention to the hands and the gestures
in particular you want to pay attention
to three things the first is where the
hands are going when we lie we tend to
the movements with their hands that we
wouldn't otherwise some of these include
covering your mouth as if that brain was
telling the body you're lying you might
get caught and there's consequences so
cover yourself the second is we scratch
your nose and we do that because we
release more adrenaline when we're
nervous when we're lying and therefore
our skin becomes it we also tend to
rubberneck over here in a reassuring
reflect that we have since we were
little kids the second part is timing
just as result mention with the facial
expressions with gestures timing is also
of the essence every time we speak and
we're gesturing at the same time we
always gesture first and then say the
words but when we lie we usually say the
words first and then do the gesture in
this video hopefully you'll be able to
see the differences and see how whenever
but I also have one side to the American
I want you to listen I'm gonna say this
again I did not have sexual relations
with that woman
this room do you believe in you know you
know if you didn't know that he was
lying you will be able to tell that
something's off there's a difference
between I did not and I do not hopefully
right now you'll be able to tell that
that difference usually implies that
someone is not being completely honest
the third thing to look for is the
position of the palms will you believe
me more if I'm talking to you like this
or if I'm talking to you like this our
palms are a part of your body that we
use to connect with other people a lot
that's why we handshake that's why we
way we'll never agree people therefore
whenever someone is lying is very hard
to do so with their palms exposed so
what we do is we they put them in our
pockets we just put them facing down or
we put them behind an object that may be
in between us and the people that we
lied to such as a desk gesturing is the
most primitive way of communication that
humans have and for that reason we tend
to do the movements very instantaneously
even when we can rehearse our words that
we say when we lie the gestures have a
mind of their own so they're more
involuntary by now hopefully you will be
able to see that if you pay attention to
where the hands go the timing of the
movement and also where the palms are
facing we'd say a lot without saying
them well Daniel just showed us the
importance of looking at the hand
gestures to detect lies and Rudolf had
mentioned the facial expressions
Jonah Mero who's been an FBI behavioral
analysis for the past 20 years an author
of what everybody is saying claims that
the most honest part of our body is
actually our feet and this is because
when we try to control our body we focus
on our facial expressions and our hands
but we often don't rehearse our feet so
there's really four main things
you should look out for with the feet
the first is how you stand so I'm
standing here with my weight equally
distributed with between both my legs
this shows that I'm much more
comfortable about what I'm saying and
I'm taking a firm stand on the subject
but if I were to cross my legs this is a
much more closed and defensive position
I'm much more uncomfortable about what
I'm saying and I'm likely to be more
nervous about it and if I were to shift
my weight from side to side or rock back
and forth this is a sign that I'm trying
to calm myself and again I'm likely
nervous about what I'm saying to you the
second thing to look out for is how
often the feet are moving so if I'm
fidgeting my feet if I'm tapping them if
I'm winding them around things it's
likely another sign that I'm
uncomfortable with what I'm saying to
you the third thing to look out for is
the direction of where my feet are
pointing this is an indication of my
interest level and my liking towards the
person that I'm talking to so if we were
to have a conversation and my feet were
pointing towards the door my torsos it
like the knees that I want to make this
and the fourth and final thing to look
out for is this concept of ankle locking
and this is where one ankle crosses the
other and this is a sign that somebody
is likely withholding information from
you for example in therapy sessions a
lot of patients will lock their ankles
as are withholding their emotions and in
negotiations if the person across from
the table from you is locking their
ankles it likely means that they're
withholding valuable concessions so for
all these reasons remember that one of
the most honest nonverbal communicators
are actually your feet so take a glance
down at somebody's feet when you're
talking to them and look out for the for
signs of lying unbalanced stance a lot
of feet movement the feet pointing away
from you and ankle walking so at this
point we've really picked apart the
nonverbals of deception we've talked to
you about the face we've talked about
the hands and we've talked to you about
the feet just to bring it back together
it's important to remember to view
behaviors in clusters so look for at
least three signs of lying before
calling foul and if you can think about
the context of what's normal for the
individual that you're observing now we
don't condone lying per se but we would
encourage you to use this knowledge not
only for others but for yourself so the
next time you're at the World Series of
Poker
don't forget your sunglasses to cover up
those dilated pupils or if that's not in
the cards consider your next tough
negotiation or interview situation we'd
love now to turn to questions would love
to hear anything that you would like to
ask us but first we want to answer what
might be the most burning question in
the room
who is lying